[Music]
foreign
service members
who was on a tour
willfully and without authorization
across the military demarcation line
it is very likely that he will be
subjected to harsh treatment
especially since he's a member of the
U.S armed forces
so that the likelihood that he will be
tortured he will face psychological
pressure he will face a physical torture
the likelihood of that happening is very
high
[Music]
foreign
they can use this as a bargaining chip
and say well you know if you want him
back you're going to have to take more
troops out of South Korea or get rid of
this nuclear you know consultative group
something like that because obviously
they have the upper hand
[Music]
oh
foreign